Mr snow
after everything you've seen out there
in the world
what are the Hunger Games for
[Music]
coming
The Hunger Games they're to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice
[Applause]
Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles not survivors
for lives
smile it's why we have teeth
I just want to know that somebody still
cared about me that I was still of value
welcome to the Capitol you look like you
shouldn't be here I shouldn't but I'm
your Mentor a rebel
I am gonna get you out of here we want
to protect people
and it's essential to accept what human
beings are
what it takes to control them
do you use that famous snow charm
you seem like a good man coylina snow I
have seen what war does to people
they're becoming prey
become predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction
engulfing the world
yeah
good luck with that poor little Songbird
where is she
and mystery series of driving people
let me ask you one final time what are
the Hunger Games oh
[Music]
it's the things we love most and destroy
us